was choosing kamala a bitter pill
for the chief of thoracic surgery dr
jill
it's funny because she's not
true
it's so
funny
true the vp pick with the annoying laugh
was not the choice of biden's better
half
and so she questioned the choice of veep
for the prez who's half asleep
according to an upcoming book my
favorite kind from two new york times
reporters who together do the job of one
first lady jill biden was against her
husband choosing kamala harris as his
running mate after she attacked him
during the primary debate of course this
would have been a great story to break
in 2020 instead of sitting on it for two
years but hey then you wouldn't be able
to sell this book allegedly in one
conversation after learning kamala was
the lead candidate jill said quote there
are millions of people in the united
states that's true
so far so good why do we have to choose
the one who attacked joe
well does she have a point let's look
back
it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country you
also worked with them to oppose bussing
and
you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me you know i
could see jill's point she didn't keep
him locked in a basement to face that
kind of abuse
so to kamal and jill get along now well
here's tape of their last get together
wow
they don't really don't like each other
but does it matter
not really because anything joe biden
does is out of his hands those in
control believe kamala still gave joe
the best chance to win and that picking
her would show the country he could be a
forgiving and unifying leader
and it's not like he remembers the
debate
but jill versus kamala that must be
awkward for joe since he thinks both of
them are the president
why not ask him
hey yeah yeah look look
come on man
so the ladies don't get along but uh
you know i gotta stick with my wife
she's a doctor did you ever hear that uh
you know apple a day keeps the doctor
away
not her
but the you know tell you the truth
uh you know vice president uh first lady
i mix them up
uh not you know not the people i know my
wife she's you know the blonde but the
the job
the job let's face it
i mean
neither one of them does anything
i know i had one of the jobs myself i
think
and um
kamala she's harmless
except for that laugh
oh man
every time she laughs i want to smash my
head on the resolute desk
[Laughter]
vivec are you surprised at how poorly
kamala has performed as a vp
uh i'm not surprised because i expected
it yeah and she's delivered on that
expectation the thing about her in that
debate performance is she tried to pose
to the american people on national
television
as some victim as a woman of color
whatever this is a kid of two tenured
professors who by the way has an older
sister that went to stanford law school
ultimately kamala harris could not
unsurprisingly not step into her bigger
sister's shoes ended up ended up taking
a very different path in what got her
ahead in the world but it's it's the
it's the fakery of it now i will
actually say you know what say what you
all about joe biden with about jill
biden if she had the good sense to tell
joe not to take kamala she did earn that
doctor i'm going to call her jill by dr
jill biden right now now that i know
that she actually had that good sense
but kamalaires that was about my
expectation she's delivered about as
poorly as we could have expected and you
know what
joe shouldn't have gone with her but he
saddled with her now you live with the
choices you make yeah you know kat uh
why didn't he listen to his spouse
because the fact is she was right this
could have say i mean and and now she
must be saying i told you so every night
but he doesn't know what she's talking
about yeah i told you so when he goes i
know but he doesn't know yeah i guess he
just um he probably wasn't allowed to
listen to her yeah that's true too i
don't know i i guess he was had some
concerns about her jill had some
concerns about her but none of the
concerns were what they should have
actually been worried about which is
that she's just not good at doing stuff
yeah
or
at saying stuff
um so she doesn't and she doesn't really
seem to care either she wants all of
this you know power and respect without
any responsibility she just goes places
and laughs at inappropriate moments
that's the only time you ever see her
yes i i find that very entertaining
tyrus you know once again we were
listening to her what did you say
bongos she needs bongos yeah every time
yeah you lost me again like i was like
oh man where's the bongos yes
but it's monday you know gene got a
haircut so you know
yeah it's like you can only do one thing
in the day yeah oh gotta run my monday
erin
yeah not i'm yes i'm a producer but busy
with my hair speaking of aaron this is
what happens when you box yourself into
a racist box
he had two choices there was stacey
abrams and her and she was more
experienced because they said they were
going to pick a woman of color to be vp
that's right instead of saying we're
going to pick the best choice even
though
both candidates
although great in their own ways one was
unsuccessful
in a political bid and the other one
competing against him and in the in the
campaign showed that she was unelectable
yeah so both showed that they were not
good choices to be vps based off
performance but performance should it
doesn't matter and the only one who was
and his wife who knows him better than
else knows his failing
memory issues of course it was upset
with somebody like they was going to
take advantage of and be rude to him and
not participate which is what she's
doing i think she's capable of doing
things if she so choose to but she's
more
interested in watching the house burn
down than actually help the biden
because then she's waiting for him to
get moved out so she gets moved in but
this is what happens when you pick off
this instead of picking with this um
there you go buck
i think that you could explain this
administration using classic 80s cinema
i would love that so for example joe
biden weekend at bernie's perhaps even
weekend at bernie's too he just has to
be there he just has to be present no
one really expects him to do anything or
be very good at anything the whole idea
was you know who he is and he's there
major league i think arguably the best
sports movie of all time charlie sheen
and wesley snipes among their finest
work they pick the absolute happy
gilmore's the best sports movie yeah i
can't believe you'd like i'm not gonna
hate all that happy girl was like a top
five but like i think major league's a
better movie nonetheless it's a very
good movie well then why haven't i seen
it
all right you were saying but as i was
so in major league the whole premise is
that they're trying to pick the absolute
worst team possible so they can relocate
from cleveland to miami right the team
owner right it's as though they were
running a competition to pick the actual
worst vice president they could when it
comes to
likability poll numbers competency
remember when she was the border czar
yeah they just made that fade because
her idea of being the borders are was
literally lying to the face of lester
holt saying we've been to the border and
he's like lady look yeah i'm gonna help
you out a lot but i can't help you out
that much you have not been to the
border so i think that she's like the
major league of
vice presidential candidate or uh vice
president if that makes any sense which
it kind of does you know what you know
who's a real the real the real winner
here is
does anybody here know the name of
kamala's spouse or could you even pick
him up out of a pick him out of a lineup
is it doug
yes that's good how did you know the
name doug i have no idea did it just pop
into it i think his name is doug i think
it is he's such a doug isn't he a doug
what's his turn
first the first guy with first game dog
first gentleman assuming he's a
gentleman i mean what if he's a ruffian
do you think the couple they do couples
things together
i hope his name really is doug no it is
doug do you think they do couple stuff
together probably not dictionary no
different two different age groups
i don't know dictionaries you got to
have four people great yeah you get like
you just sit at home like picture with
one other people no i meant the four
times four of them i met four of them i
met the two couples oh the the president
no not even a little bit they don't even
cross in the hallway they like take
turns in the
communal kitchen at the white house
all right up next will disney pull up
stakes
because there are no more tax breaks hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else